معنا من الحرم المكيه الشريف مراسل
العربيه هاني نصفيان اهلا بك كل عام وانت
بخير رمضان كريم انقل لنا الصوره من عندك
ثاني
نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين قناه
العربيه من ساحه الحرم المكي في مكه
المكرمه حيث ننقل الان قبل دخول وقت اذان
المغرب والبدء والاستعداد لوجبه الافطار
التي تقوم بها جهات رقابيه وكذلك جمعيات
معتمده في اماره منطقه مكه المكرمه هذه
الوجبات تتجاوز عددها المليون ونصف
المليون وجبه توزع يوميا على المعتمرين
والزوار المسجد الحرام عموما مع الاستاذ
علاء الجباس ومدير اداره البرامج والتطوير
في جمعيه هديه واحده لجمعيات التي
المعتمده لدى امرت منطقه مكه المكرمه
والتي تقومون ايضا بتوزيع هذه الوجبات
اليوم كيف نتحدث عن اليه التوزيع في ظل
هذه الاعداد الكبيره والكثافه العديديه
شكرا اخوي هاني يعطيك العافيه طبعا نحن في
جمعيه هديه الحاج والمعتمر احدى الجمعيات
لتقدم وجبات الافطار صائم في ساحات مسجد
الحرام
اكثر من صنف من الوجبات نقدم داخل الحدود
الحرم وخارجها
الوجبات في وجبات مكيفه فيها سبع منتجات
تقدم من
قبل المتبرعين
نقدم مثل هذه الوجبات تقريبا ما يزيد عن
الاربعين الف وجبه
بالاضافه الى السقيا نقدم تقريبا ما يقارب
مليونين عبوه
سقيا في
في مكه المكرمه دائما نطلع على الصوره هذه
هذه شكل الوجبه ميسون تاتي بهذا الغلاف
ويتم توزيعها على المعتمرين والزوار تتكون
من التمر وكذلك مواد خفيفه غنيه بالبروتين
والالياف وكذلك بعض العصائر الطبيعيه
وكذلك مياه زمزم كما تفضل ساعود لك استاذ
علاء ولكن الان نلتقط هذه الصور التي يتم
تو زيع الان في هذه اللحظات وجبات الافطار
وايضا بالصناديق عديده طبعا هذه الصناديق
تحمل في داخلها اكثر من 50 غلافا او حقيبه
غذائيه يتم توزيعها على المصلين وكذلك
المعتمرين الذين الان يتواجدون بكثافه
عدديه في هذه اللحظات ويزداد العدد اكثر
واكثر قبل دخول المغرب